Hi, my name is Marc Mencher, president of GameRecruiter.com...
...and we're here at DarkSide Game Studios in Fort Lauderdale, Florida.
The average salary for a video game programmer in our industry is about $85,000 base salary.
On top of that, we have a bonus or a profit - sharing program,...
...so although the salaries are slightly less starting off than you'd see in the general business community,...
...those people do not have royalties or bonus programs like we see in the video game industry.
So for example, the folks at id Software,...
...none of them are crying about the million dollars bonus they get a year on top of their base salary.
Of course $85,000 is the average salary in the United States.
You obviously want to consider the cost of living in the areas that you're living in.
The West Coast, San Francisco, Los Angeles would be slightly more expensive cost of living...
...than Las Vegas, Nevada, or places like that.
So it's an average number to keep in mind when you're job hunting.